INTEL INSPECTOR GENERAL AND
ABOUT JOHN DURHAM’S
INVESTIGATION.
BUT FIRST, THIS IS AMERICA AND
SHUT DOWN DAY 24.
SOME IMPORTANT DEVELOPMENTS.
AND SOME EMAILS THAT I MUST
SHARE WITH YOU.
AS NEW YORK REMAINS THE COVID
CAULDRON OF AMERICA, 799 MORE
FOLKS IN NEW YORK DIED
YESTERDAY, BRINGING THE STATE
TOTAL TO A STAGGERING 7,067.
NOW, THAT’S 43% OF ALL AMERICAN
FATALITIES, TO GET YOUR MIND
WRAPPED AROUND THAT.
THE PUBLIC HOSPITALS ESPECIALLY
REMAIN BATTLEGROUNDS, BUT THE
STATE OVERALL CONTINUES TO MAKE
SOME PROGRESS AGAINST THE VIRUS.
>> WE HAD 200 NET INCREASE IN
HOSPITALIZATIONS, WHICH YOU CAN
SEE IS THE LOWEST NUMBER WE’VE
HAD THIS NIGHTMARE STARTED.
A CHANGE IN ICU ADMISSIONS IS
THE LOWEST NUMBER WE’VE HAD
SINCE MARCH 19TH OR SO.
THE NUMBER OF INTIMATIONS IS
DOWN.
>> Laura: THAT’S ALL GOOD NEWS
NEWS.
NEW YORK CITY IS STRETCHED AND
HURTING, THE SYSTEM, THE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM, WHAT WE WERE
WORRIED ABOUT, IT’S GOING TO
BEND, BUT IT’S NOT GOING TO
BREAK, THANK GOODNESS, IT’S NOT
GOING TO COLLAPSE.
WITH THIS IN MIND, IT IS TRULY
SHOCKING TO SEE HOW FAR OFF
ALMOST EVERY MODEL WAS THAT
INFORMED THE DRACONIAN RESPONSE
OF A NATIONWIDE SHUTDOWN, A
ONE-SIZE-FITS-ALL KIND OF
SHUTDOWN ALTHOUGH THE PRESIDENT
GAVE THE STATES SOME
FLEXIBILITY, WHICH IS REALLY
SMART.
FIRST, NEW YORK COVID BID
PROJECTIONS WERE TOTALLY WRONG.
LOOK AT THIS GRAPH.
THE PURPLE DOTTED LINE IS WHERE
WE ARE TODAY, ABOUT 18,000 BEDS
NEEDED.
THE RED LINE IS THE IH AND THE
MODEL BY BILL GATES.
THE GREENLINE IS COLUMBIA
UNIVERSITY’S ESTIMATE.
LOOK AT WHERE THAT WAS.
ANOTHER WAS FROM THE McKENZIE
GROUP.
LOOK AT THAT DOTTED LINE BELOW,
THAT IS WHERE WE ACTUALLY ARE.
THIS IS GREAT NEWS BUT THESE
ESTIMATES WERE OFF BY A FACTOR
OF 6!
THE HIGH-END MORTALITY
PREDICTIONS IS EVEN WORSE AND AS
WE’VE SPOKEN ABOUT BEFORE, THAT
WAS OFF BY A FACTOR OF 33.
THAT’S NOT THAT GRAPH, IT’S A
DIFFERENT ONE.
NEW ORLEANS IS GOING THROUGH A
VERY TOUGH TIME, BUT THINGS ARE
EVEN LOOKING UP THERE.
>> WE DO BELIEVE WE ARE
BEGINNING TO SEE THE FLATTENING
OF THE CURVE, BUT WE THEN HAVE
TO COME DOWN ON THE OTHER SIDE
AND WE KNOW THE CASES CAN SPIKE.
WE WILL BE EASING BACK TOWARDS
LIFE AS WE LIVED IT BEFORE
COVID-19.
>> Laura: WELL, EVERYONE
NORMAN’S LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT
THAT.
PHILADELPHIA IS SHOWING MODEST
SIGNS OF NEW CASES LEVELING OFF
AS WELL.
THAT’S GOOD NEWS.
SO THEY SAY THAT IT’S THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING THAT’S FLATTENING THE
CURVE, BUT IT’S ALSO CAUSING
ANOTHER HORRIFIC DECLINE, THE
ONGOING ISOLATION, ESPECIALLY
AMONG OUR ELDERLY, IS TAKING ITS
TOLL.
ALEXANDRA SAW HER FATHER IN
EARLY MARCH, THE CORONAVIRUS WAS
IN THE EARLY SMOLDERING STAGE OF
ITS WILDFIRE SPREAD ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
SOON AFTERWARDS, HIS NURSING
HOME IN THE SUBURBS OF
WASHINGTON, D.C., WAS CLOSED TO
VISITORS.
NOT LONG AFTER THAT HER FATHER,
DANA, 75, WAS CONFINED TO HIS
ROOM ALONG WITH ALL OTHER
RESIDENTS.
HE SLEEPS PROBABLY 18 HOURS A
DAY.
I CALL HIM EVERY DAY WHEN I’M
ABLE, SHE SAID.
BUT HE DOESN’T ALWAYS PICK UP.
SINCE HE HAS PARKINSON’S DISEASE
AND NOW NO ACCESS TO PHYSICAL OR
SPEECH THERAPY, IT’S
INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT TO
UNDERSTAND HIM.
AND SHE WORRIES THAT ONGOING
ISOLATION COULD ACCELERATE HIS
DECLINE.
THAT’S HEARTBREAKING.
WE HAVE TO BRING ME STORIES TO
LIGHT AS WELL.
I ALSO GOT THIS TEXT FROM A
FRIEND WHO RUNS A LANDSCAPE
DESIGN FIRM IN SOUTH FLORIDA.
HE SAID THIS PAYCHECK PROTECTION
PLAN IS A MESS.
I KNOW A LARGE CROSS-SECTION OF
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IN MANY DIFFERENT FIELDS
AND WITH A VARIETY OF BANKS.
NO ONE I KNOW SEEN A DIME, WE’RE
JUST DYING OUT HERE, WE JUST GOT
TWO-THIRDS OF OUR STAFF AND PUT
THE REST ON HALFPENNY.
NOTHING IS MOVING ON BY THE TIME
SBA LOANS ARE PROCESSED WE WILL
ALL BE IN 2021.
WHAT PELOSI DID TODAY IS
UNBELIEVABLY DISPIRITING.
A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER’S LIVES
MATTER.
CANNOT WAIT UNTIL THINGS ARE
BACK TO NORMAL.
I’LL SAY.
SO WHAT DID PELOSI DO TODAY?
WHAT IS HE TALKING ABOUT?
SHE MADE IT CLEAR -- I KNOW THIS
IS HARSH TO SAY BUT IT SEEMS
LIKE DEMOCRATS AND CONGRESS
ALMOST WANT AS MANY AMERICANS
OUT OF WORK ON ELECTION DAY AS
POSSIBLE.
SCHUMER AND PELOSI HELD UP A NEW
AID PACKAGE FOR SMALL BUSINESS
BECAUSE IT DOESN’T CONTAIN ALL
THE LEFT-WING GOODIES THEY WANT.
ALL THE G.O.P. WANTED TO DO WAS
LITERALLY CHANGE ONE NUMBER.
AT THE $250 BILLION IN THE
STIMULUS FOR SMALL BUSINESS
WOULD BECOME 600 BILLION.
ADD ANOTHER 250 -- I THINK IT
WAS AT 350, IT WOULD BECOME
600 BILLION.
WHAT THEY ARE SAYING, IN OTHER
WORDS, THE DEMOCRATS, IS OUR
AGENDA IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
YOUR SURVIVAL, THE SURVIVAL OF
FIRMS LIKE THE ONE I JUST
REFERENCED.
PLUS, THE UNELECTED MEDICAL
BUREAUCRATS, WHAT ARE THEY KEEP
DOING?
THEY KEEP MOVING THE GOAL POSTS
FOR WHEN THEY THINK THE ECONOMY
CAN REOPEN.
TRUMP WAS RIGHT A MONTH AGO WHEN
HE SAID THIS.
>> DON’T FORGET, THE DOCTORS --
IF IT WERE UP TO THE DOCTORS
THEY MAY SAY LET’S KEEP IT
SHUTDOWN, LET’S SHUTDOWN THE
ENTIRE WORLD, LET’S KEEP IT SHUT
FOR THE COUPLE OF YEARS.
>> Laura: DR. FAUCI HIMSELF
HAS DISMISSED AS ANECDOTAL,
CHEAP, SCALABLE, DECADES-OLD
THERAPIES THAT ARE ALREADY VITAL
WEAPONS IN THE BATTLE AGAINST
COVID-19.
THEY SHOW REAL PROMISE IN
KEEPING PEOPLE NOT JUST OUT OF
THE ICU, BUT OUT OF THE HOSPITAL
ALTOGETHER, JUST LIKE THE CDC
DIRECTOR, THEY ARE LIKE THIS ON
THE ISSUE.
ON THIS SUBJECT, BIG NEWS TODAY,
FRENCH PRESIDENT EMMANUEL MACRON
MADE A SURPRISE TRIP TO
MARSEILLE TODAY TO THE
INFECTIOUS DISEASE INSTITUTE --
A RENOWNED EPIDEMIOLOGIST.
HE WAS HANDED THE RESULTS OF A
FOLLOW-UP STUDY OF MORE THAN
1,061 COVID PATIENTS THAT WERE
PUT ON A REGIMEN OF
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE AND
AZITHROMYCIN.
THE PULMONARY REPORT CONTAINS
SOME VERY GOOD NEWS.
THE RESULTS ARE STILL BEING
ANALYZED, BUT THE HEALING WAS
ACHIEVED IN 973 OF THE PATIENTS
IN TEN DAYS.
FOR AN EFFICACY RATE OF 91%.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE CRITICS WHO
CITED POSSIBLE SERIOUS
COMPLICATIONS OF THESE DRUGS?
WELL, THE PROFESSOR FOUND ZERO
CARDIAC COMPLICATIONS IN ANY OF
HIS SUBJECTS.
AMERICA HAS SOME CLINICAL TRIALS
OF ITS OWN GOING ON RIGHT NOW,
BUT THIS FRENCH DATA CONFIRMS
WHAT OUR OWN DR. STEPHEN SMITH,
HE’LL BE ON IN A FEW MOMENTS,
FOUND IN HIS INFECTIOUS DISEASE
PRACTICE AS WELL.
THIS IS GOOD NEWS, AND THANK THE
GOOD LORD WE HAVE A PRESIDENT
WHO RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANCE OF
ADVANCING THESE MEDICAL
SOLUTIONS AS FAST AND AS SAFELY
AS POSSIBLE.
A STARK REMINDER OF HOW FAR WE
HAVE FALLEN BECAUSE OF THIS
VIRUS AND OF COURSE THE
SHUTDOWN.
IN EARLY FEBRUARY WE HAD LONG
LINES TO GET INTO CLUBS AND
NEIGHBORHOOD HOT SPOTS.
BUT IN EARLY APRIL AMERICANS ARE
NOW LINING UP FOR BASIC
NECESSITIES.
>> OVER 1200 CARS LINED UP AT
THE STADIUM IN SAN DIEGO OVER
THE WEEKEND.
>> WHEN THEY SEE THAT BOX OF
FOOD COMING INTO THE CARS, SOME
OF THEM SMILE AND SOME OF THEM
CRY.
>> Laura: IS THE PRESIDENT
SAID, THE SHUTDOWN, WHAT IT’S
DOING, WHAT IT’S OBVIOUSLY DONE
TO THE INCOME EARNING POTENTIAL
OF PEOPLE, WE HAVE RECORD
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE AT FOOD BANKS,
EVEN IN BOSTON, A FRIEND OF MINE
TOLD ME THE OTHER DAY, HE
COULDN’T BELIEVE WHAT HE SAW.
THE PRESIDENT SAID THE STATE
THAT WE ARE IN, THIS IS LIKE
SUSPENDED STATE OF ANIMATION, IS
UNNATURAL.
IT CANNOT CONTINUE INDEFINITELY.
CERTAINLY CAN CONTINUE MUCH
LONGER.
WE HAVE TO ADAPT TO NEW
INFORMATION, NEW DATA AND WHEN
THE PROJECTIONS ARE OFF, AS
THEY’VE BEEN OFF, WE
DEMONSTRATED, ACTUALLY ALMOST
FOR TWO WEEKS NOW, OUR RESPONSE
TO THAT CRISIS HAS TO BE SMARTLY
ADJUSTED AND ALSO SAFELY.
SOME NEW REALITIES, NEW
PROTOCOLS, A PHASED IN
REOPENING.
MEASURES THAT WORK FOR NEW YORK
WHERE THINGS ARE STILL VERY
TOUGH MIGHT NOT BE NECESSARY IN
NEBRASKA.
THAT’S OKAY.
BUT UNLESS SOMEHOW MONEY REALLY
JUST DOES GROW ON TREES, WE NEED
A REOPENING SOON, A DATE CERTAIN
WHERE WE CAN CONTINUE PROTECTING
THE MOST VULNERABLE AND AT THE
SAME TIME RECLAIM OUR LIVES AND
OUR GOD-GIVEN FREEDOM.
THOSE ARE MY THOUGHTS AT THE END